hello everyone
my name is surya and i'll be presenting
our work title mixing of three term
progressions in quasi random groups this
is a joint work
with amengale and prahlada dharshan
we'll start with a very popular result
in theory computer science which is
called the expander mixing lemma the
lemma says if h is an expander graph on
the vertex set v
and set e and we take two functions f1
and f2 from the vertices to the complex
numbers both of them are bounded
functions
then these two expressions are
approximately equal to each other
so what we have over here so in the
right hand side we have product of
expectations of individual functions
and this expectation is computed over
the uniform distributions on the
vertices
on the right hand side we are
computing the expectation over the
distribution uh uv randomly sampled from
the set e
and computing the quantity f1 of u times
f2 of v
okay
and
uh the lemma says this two quantities
are roughly equal and that is a good
news because we know there are constant
degree expander graphs and we know how
to construct them efficiently so let's
if we take like a expander graph
on a constant degree d
and consider right term and left term so
we look at the
distribution so the right hand side we
have distribution over roughly v square
number of elements on the left hand side
we have a distribution over roughly d
times v number of elements
okay so if d is a constant with respect
to the cardinality of the set v then d
times v is way smaller compared to the
coordinate of v square
so this is nice example where you know
random behavior and it has a lot of
application
now we focus
on a similar question but in a slightly
different uh setting
so
instead of taking h2p graph we take h to
be three uniform hyper graphs
uh so now now let's uh take three
functions f1 f2 and f3 and again compare
uh terms uh
as before so on the right hand side what
we have we have product of expectations
of individual function on the left hand
side again we sample u v and w uh which
is a hyper h from the set uh then we
compute f 1 of u f 2 of e
times f times f3 fw
okay
and we
consider
uh
studying this mixing phenomena over
specific hyper graphs where the vertex s
set
is going to be
a group g what kind of hyper graphs we
are talking about over here uh there
will be two of them h1 and h2 where h1
will be a hyper graph on uh on the
vertex group g
and their set will be e1 and how e1 is
defined is the set of all non-trivial
triples like this x comma y comma x
times y where both x y belongs to g
and non-trivial meaning we ignore all
the triples where either x or y is
identity
okay uh so h1 is defined that way h2 for
h2 the vertex that is again a group g ah
the set e2 is defined using a slightly
different pattern so it is the set of
all non-trivial triples
uh like this x comma x times y comma x
times y square this is the set of all
non trivial three term progression
in g
now one might wonder what is exactly the
motivation behind studying mixing
phenomena over these hyper graphs so
let's uh talk about uh h1 first
so mixing for h1
implies that if we take any large subset
a within g that is not going to be
product free
or equivalently take any
large subset a and g then there will be
a non-trivial triple x comma y comma x
times y where all three of them will be
in a
and to see this
why why this is true
so uh
fix any
large subset a within g and uh take f1
f2 and f3 to be the indicator function
of this set a
now
because a is very large this right side
will be a non-zero element
and from mixing it will follow the left
hand side will also be non-zero
okay so
we have the left hand side
to be non-zero but if a was indeed
product free then the left hand side
must be
zero
so
uh it follows that the um
subset a is actually not product free
because we know the left hand side is
actually is nonzero
right so this is the rough uh idea
behind the argument
and uh
certainly there are groups where we
cannot hope to get
any
meaningful mixing
result uh over the graph over the hyper
graph h1 for example if uh if g is a
billion
uh
then
th this kind of mixing will not be able
to see uh and simply because of the
reason
every a billion group actually has large
property or
some free sets
so uh we cannot hope to get those kind
of mixing for a billion groups but there
are certain group special kind of groups
for which mixing actually happens for
each one
so in 2008 gower's proof that
mixing for h1
happens when the group g is d quasi
random
okay specifically prove the following if
g is a finite d quasi random group
then
the two terms we are concerned with they
are close to each other
by
this error factor one over square root
of t
okay
uh we haven't quite defined formally
what the quasi random groups are uh
we'll do this later but right now we
just assume okay take d to be a very
large uh integer
then we can see if uh if g is a
d quasi random group then um
we'll have a really good mixing for the
hyper graph h1
so as d
kind of goes to infinity
this error term we have over here goes
to 0
and
one point i'd like to note over here so
in this work hours first define
the concept of quasi random groups and
initiated of a study of such groups
uh later
you know several results have been
proven
about these kind of groups uh and some
of which also found application in
theoretical computer science
okay so let's continue our discussion
and uh let's focus on the other hyper
graph now which is the hyper graph h2
here uh again that just to recall the
edge set uh is basically uh the set of
all non-trivial progression three term
progressions in g
so now a mixing for the hyper graph h2
will actually imply any large
a
any large subset a in g will not be
three term progression free
okay
so and the argument is same as before
that we just discussed
uh
and governs in the same paper from 2008
um
in the central very defined what
question groups are he conjecture
the
mixing uh over the hyper graph h2
when the underlying group g is d quasi
random
okay so here is the conjecture uh by
covers so let g be a finite d quantum
group and
uh again we pick the functions which are
bounded once
then we again we compare these two terms
uh
then the absolute value of this
difference is bounded by
uh some little of some little of one
turn
uh
now
this is the conjecture
covers uh for the hyper graph h2
and we'll refer to that is thus
conjecture on mixing of three term
progression and our main result in this
paper is we prove this conjecture
for all
uh
the quasi random groups okay so this is
the precise result we prove in the paper
let's uh take g to be a finite deposit
random group
then
we
compare these two terms where on the
left hand side we sample uh x and y
randomly from g and construct the three
terms regression x x y and x squared and
compute this expectation on the right
hand side we simply have the product of
expectations and
these two quantities will be close to
each other module of this error term
which is 2 over square drop d taken to
the power 1 by 4. so this is the
main result in this paper that we proved
now
uh
let's try to formally define what the
quasi random groups are and to do that
we have to define first what group
representation are so let's start with
that
so here's the first definition so our
representation row of a group g on a
finite dimensional
vector space v is simply a group
homomorphism
from the group g
to the
to the general linear group over the
vector space v
okay so it's basically uh taking the
group elements to invertible
linear transformation over the vector
specific
now we use d row to denote the dimension
of a representation row which is simply
the dimension of the underlying
vector space ah we on which the
representation row is acting on
ah for us all the vector spaces
that we'll deal with will be over
complex numbers
uh here is an example of a
representation which is called the
trivial representation so if you take v
to be the vector space
of complex numbers which is the one
dimension vector space then we can
define rho x to be just one or
for all x in g
uh and this is called the trivial
representation and we can define it for
any group g
and uh
from now onward we'll just write rho
assuming
there is some vector space v that is it
is i am acting upon
so we'll keep that implicit
here is another definition that would be
useful to define what question groups
are it's called irreducible
representation
so first let me define what reducible
representation are so a representation
rho is called reducible if there exists
a non trivial subspace w
of v
or we in v such that
rho x the linear transformation rho x
applied to w
uh
keeps uh
all the vectors within w um
all the vectors from w when you apply
rho x on them
we um
we keep them like within w so rho x
doesn't move the vectors
uh
within w outside of w
okay and this is true for all the x and
g
so
if this happens then we call the
representation row is
reducible
otherwise we call it rho is irreducible
okay so this is the formal definition
another uh kind of informally um
informal way to kind of think about them
is
a representative row is called reducible
if they can be further you know broken
into
other representations
uh on the other hand it's called it's
called irreducible if they
if rho cannot be broken into
for the representation
okay so that's the idea behind
irreducible representation
uh here is a short note about notation
so g hat will denote
the set uh uh
the finite and unique uh
set of uh
all
irreducible representation unique in the
sense like up to isomorphism okay so
before we move on uh here's another
example uh so example of irreducible
representation
so for
the group g
[Music]
symmetry group s3
there is a degree two irreducible
representation row that takes group
elements to two dimensional matrices
such as for example if we apply row to
the group element one comma two then it
takes it to the
this matrix one zero zero minus one
similarly it takes other group elements
to other matrices
so that's one example
now we can define quasi and what
question and groups are
okay so what's the different definition
so a finite group g d
g is called d quasi random
if it's all non-trivial irreducible
representations are at least d dimension
okay so that's that's the dimension
um that's the definition uh here are
some examples so a billion groups are
one osce random
so we can readily see that gauss's
theorem
uh about the hypergraph h1 uh mixing
hyperglyph h1 uh that doesn't say
anything about ability groups because
it's one quasi random so you do not get
any meaningful error bomb
okay
but there are other
groups which are highly quasi random for
example if you consider the group sl to
f where f is the finite field then
there's going to be size of the finite
field quasi random
card and if you take really really large
finite field then
it will be you know more and more uh
quasi random
uh uh another kind of example is like if
you consider any non-billion finite
simple group meaning the groups which
doesn't have any non trivial normal sub
group
if you consider such groups
of order n then that would be square
root of log n divided by 2 cos lambda
ok so if the group size increases
if it's really really large then it will
be also very very positive
so now let's compare our result with
known results uh
in context of this conjecture so tau in
2013 proved this conjecture or showed
mixing for three term progression when
the group g is sldfq
and for this tao used algebraic geometry
machinery
to prove the result and then in 2018
pelus extended the result to all finite
simple groups
uh to do that police used kind of
elementary fourier techniques to reduce
the problem to bounding a sum like this
right it is a sum of one over d rho
where rho belongs to g hat which is the
set of called irreducible representation
except rho cannot be the trivial one so
she reduce it to sum like this
and
this quantity is equals to
zeta g minus 1 where zeta j is the width
and zeta function of g
and zeta g minus 1 is small of ah or
little o of 1 for all finite simple
groups except for like a specif uh let's
say for one specific group psl to f
uh
this term is
small
and this is a result this is by a result
due to uh now
liebeck and charlotte from 2004 and
pelosi uses this result to get the final
bound on the final simple groups
okay now we talk about our
result so we prove that first of all we
prove the conjecture for all finite
position groups
more interestingly the second point is
our proof uses only elementary fourier
uh
and
the third point is we also achieve
better error parameter compared to
pillars
that's like the rough comp
kind of
comparison between
our work and the previous works
now let's talk about the proof of the
theorem so this is the theorem we are
interested in proving
uh and which is equivalent to proving
this statement so these two theorems are
almost same except we over here we have
this additional assumption that the
expected value of the function f3
is zero
and that allows us to remove this broad
to expectation term we can just
get rid of it and work with a simpler
looking term over here
and we can assume this without loss of
generality because we can just shift the
function if it's even if it's not mean
zero so that's fine so you want to show
this
and the proof is roughly divided into
two main steps
uh step one is
repeated application of cauchy force and
change of variables
in order to reduce the problem into you
know bounding a simpler term which
involves only f3 or the third function
then in step two use
basic fourier to bound the term from
step one
so that's the overall structure
so let's uh briefly discuss how step one
looks like
so step one is this uh you know you use
cauchy shorts and change your values to
so so this quantity we start with is
less than equals to some quantity only
involving f3
here is an example step uh how it goes
so this is the starting point
over here
first we would do one change of
variables so previously we are doing
sampling a and b both from g and setting
this a
uh
setting this pattern to be a a b and a b
square
now uh we do change our variable we set
we take on a b to b x um
and then also
change b to y
then we have a
new uh expression is the same as the
previous expression both of the same
so this is just a little algebra
manipulation then we do a cauchy source
over x
this allows us to remove the function f2
so okay so we apply cautions and reach
over here doesn't it have f2
similarly if we
kind of do another cautious shot we'll
be able to remove f1 as well
uh
so that's the rough idea behind step one
and now that we are done with step one
the problem roughly reduces to bounding
or term like this which is expected
value of an l2 norm
of a function
or like this
and this function is a convolution of
two functions this h function and the mu
function what these functions are so
h z of x is the mean zero
projection of this product function
which is f three of x times f g of x c
and to define mu function so for any
subset s in g mu s is defined to be the
indicator function of s up to
normalization factor
and c of g is the conjugate class of g
okay so
this function is basically
an indicator function of this subset g
inverse cg inverse
and this function h function is the mean
zero position of this
product function which is a discrete
analog of the derivative operator in
some sense
okay so now that we
uh are done with step one let's let's
have a quick recap
about where we are and how should we
proceed from here
so we started with this initial term
um
applied a bunch of uh cost shorts and
change of variables
uh
and some other algebra manipulations to
reach over here
so now we need to bound this
one quick note over here so this
step one which is repeated application
of course works
uh is com um is also there in taos proof
as well as in pelosi's group so it's
common to um all of our work
and this technique was introduced by
gowers
initially uh
in the context of bounding
expressions like this
over abelian groups
then tao later in his work adapted that
same technique in the non-billion world
and
pelus and our work also uses the same
steps
okay so now that we have
uh we have we have successfully reduced
the task to bounding
our term like this which only involves
the function f3 inside it
now the approach of taos
values and hours kind of diverges uh
from each other
at this point
so on the left hand side this left arrow
is kind of denoting tau's approach
so
tau
reduce the task
to
estimating quantities like ybh
ah where ybs is the
coordinate of this set
we will not discuss what this set is in
detail
ah rather we like we'd like to point out
um how does this reduction as well as
the estimation using algebraic geometric
techniques uh those from
algebraic geometry including
ah the very familiar source simple lemma
in the middle arrow we have
pelusa's approach which we already
discussed
basically she reduced the task to
bounding uh sum like this one over t row
and uh
this is bounded
for finite simple groups
because of the bound on
ah within zeta function due to
lee vacant
solid
okay now on the right hand side this
arrow is denoting our approach which is
basically using elementary food analysis
and we'll discuss more on this
so before
we go into slightly more details let us
recall some facts from non obedient
fourier these are all basic facts
so first of all
uh for any complex matrix we'll uh
the he the hilbert schmidt norm
of the
inverse non square of the matrix is
simply the trace
of this matrix product so it's
conjugate transpose of m times m itself
we take the trace of it and get the
hilbert's minimum square
and
uh let's go over four very basic facts
uh
from non-billion fourier so the first
one is about the fourier coefficient of
f with respect to any representation rho
it is denoted by f hat of rho and it is
simply this expected value this
expectation of this f x rho x
so if rho is
more than one dimensional f hatter pro
will be a matrix
now let's
talk about the fourier inversion formula
which is f x
equals to you know again uh sub sum over
rho in g hat 0 times stress of this
quantity which is conjugate transpose of
f rho times r of x
the partial identity is also there in
this non-billion world so l two norm of
f square is equals to the sum of the
hilbert ah hilbert screen norm square of
effect row multiplied by 0
and finally we have
uh
the fourier convolution formula which is
the
which says the fourier coefficient of
the
function f convolved with g
at rho is equals to the fourier
coefficient of f time
for equation g
along with this we're going to use one
more fact uh
so me this function mu g c g
we already talked about it has a very
nice fourier expression and from that we
can reduce that expected value of g of
this quantity that the hilbert's mean
square norm square of this inner
quantity
this is equals to 1
over 0
and this fact we'll use uh later in the
proof and this fact was also used by
sarah pelus as well
okay
now uh let's look at the proof
uh first of all we induce the notation a
bit and write only mu cg instead of
writing mu g inverse cg inverse
and
let's start with the quantity that we
had after step one so this is the
quantity we had the first and the most
uh important observation over here is
uh after we have sample g and fixed g
then ah we uniformly um infinite random
sample b
and look at the distributions on
of g inverse bg that will be also
uniformly random over the group g
so what we can do instead of computing
the g inverse b g
ignore that completely off and just
replace it with the b itself
okay so now
uh that we have this the next steps are
quite easy
so we first use possible's identity to
write this l2
norm as a sum of
hilbert spin not
and then
we
use the fourier
convolution formula to separate
this two coefficients
and furthermore we bring in
when they're
separated out
we bring in
another fact about hilbert schmidt norm
which is hilbertsman nonsense is known
to be some multiplicative meaning
the
norm of the product is can be upper
bounded by the product of the norms
so we use that to completely separate
out this two fourier coefficient
and also we bring in this averaging over
g inside
now
we use the fact we discussed
about the function mu cg
so this average
is equals to 1 over d rho
and that 0 cancels this 2.
so now we are only left with this
expression
okay so now
we are basically done because the
expression we have over here what you
can do
inside we can multiply
and divide by d rho because d rho is at
least upper case t we can take one by
uppercase d outside
ah and
this expression will be bounded by
one by uppercase t times expectation of
the sum times d rho times the hilbert
spin not
and this is the l2 norm of the function
hp which is bounded by one so this
express this expected value is at most 1
so we are done
this entire expression is bounded by 1
over d
so this was the rough sketch
of the proof
just to conclude what we showed in this
work is mixing of three term
progressions for finite quasi random
groups the next natural question is of
course uh considering longer
progressions or like k term progressions
for arbitrary k
another interesting direction could be
uh possible applications in complexity
theory so we know
applications are mixing in quasi random
groups
of in complexity theory though for other
kinds of patterns
and it would be interesting if you can
find also applications for
progressions as well
and this was
the talk and thank you for listening